As you know,
I encourage viewers
to call in
and leave us voice mails,
but I never have time
to listen to them.
Our crew at The Opposition has
put some voice mails together
that I have honestly
never heard before,
but I promise
to answer any questions
and vomit my thoughts
straight at you.
I have citizen journalist
Tim Baltz joining me
to add his expertise.
I can't wait to tear these
people new assholes, Jordan.
Right, Tim. Well...
I think those are mostly fans
of the show, so...
Oh, yeah.
I mean in a helpful way.
Right. Well, I'm excited
to hear what you have to say.
-Chuck, let's fire up
the first call. -(beep)
Hi, Jordan.
This is Diane from Chesterland.
And I want to know why are all
the actors in Hollywood liberal?
I mean, I feel like
they're just Democratic pawns.
I get the feeling
they're being told what to say,
-where to stand, how to look.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's disgusting.
-Yeah.
And, I mean, the whole place--
it's a liberal infestation.
Hollywood? Why not Holly coal?
-Huh. Oh, God, that's good.
-(chuckling): Oh.
-Wow. -They say conservatives
can't do comedy, right?
That was... She made a really,
really great point,
though, all right?
And it gets to something that we
have talked about on this show.
-Yup.
-Is that Hollywood is scripted.
It's almost like
they have people writing lines,
and then they read the lines,
and then they say the lines.
Here's a funny thing.
There's an area in New York
that you can go to.
They call it SoHo. It stands
for "north of Houston."
-Okay.
-And...
And what I've seen it is,
these, uh... these libs
sell what they call
"screenplays,"
and they're actual scripts
of the words that are being said
in movies, in famous movies.
Almost Famous.
Uh, The Godfather.
The Godfather: Part III.
Uh, and if you flip through it,
it's the exact words
that these so-called actors,
these, uh... these human beings,
these liberal with their own
points of view...
It's the same words
that they say on screen.
Hold on.
Flip through it?
Are you saying
that it's on paper
when they could put it
on an iPad and not waste paper?
Thank you. Um...
See, this is where
they're hypocritical, Jordan.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. -This is where
they're hypocritical.
Yeah, yeah, they want us
to cut up
our little six-packs of plastic
so that birds in the ocean
don't eat it and die
when birds live in the sky,
and fish live in the ocean.
(laughter)
It's-it's so easy
to pull this apart.
You pull one string, and the
whole ball of spaghetti
becomes unra...
unraveled, you know?
-It totally is.
-(applause)
Unbelievable.
Uh, let's hear our next call.
-(beep)
-MAN: Hi, Jordan?
I got a bit of a problem.
I hate Justin Trudeau
and all of his liberal,
long-haired ideas.
But I also recognize
that he is a handsome man.
-Yeah. -And I'm not sure
what to do about that
-Mm.
-because... ooh,
I hate him so much,
I want to kiss him!
-This is the category I call
"Oops, he's hot." -Mm-hmm.
(laughter, applause)
You had, uh...
Obama fit in this category
for just a second, right?
-Which has stopped. Yeah.
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
When Obama was on the campaign
trail, I was, "Oops, he's hot."
-Mm-hmm. -And then, the second
he put his hand on the bible
and got sworn in, I was like,
"Something's not right.
-We need to take him down."
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Well, you see a man
shirtless kite-sailing,
and you're gonna have
an instinctive response.
My response was,
"Oops, he's hot."
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
That's a human response.
People can have
an "Oops, he's hot" reaction.
That doesn't mean
that you're gonna support them.
that you're gonna vote for them.
That means
that you will eventually, uh,
probably go into a side room,
uh, turn off all of the lights,
uh, and try to repress
the feelings that you have,
build that into a ball of anger
and then
aim that anger at that person
that you cared about,
uh, just hours earlier.
It's normal.
Uh, but seriously,
shout-out to...
shout-out to you
because the first time
I met you, I thought,
"Oops, he's hot."
And to be honest,
there are times
when Jordan still does things,
and I think, "Oops, he's hot."
So it endures.
(laughter)
(laughter continues)
-Are you gonna...? -Oh,
let's get another call, Chuck.
Jordan! This is Grace
from Northampton, Mass.
-Love it. -I run
a mixed martial arts studio
for women and their dogs, and we
have this argument all the time.
Which Founding Father would win
in a cage match melee fight?
I love your show.
Love you, man. Love Grace.
It's a great question.
I think obviously people are
gonna go with Abraham Lincoln.
He's gangly, he's large,
he has a top hat, uh...
he knows to at least be
on the receiving end of a gun,
-and so, uh...
-(laughter, groaning)
No, but your point is fair--
violence begets violence.
Exactly. Uh-huh, uh-huh, yeah.
That's why, like, you know, if
you punish a kid with violence,
-they're gonna get tougher.
Uh-huh. -Yep.
Uh, Andrew Jackson
is a clear one.
Andrew Johnson, also,
a tough, uh, scrappy guy.
-Yep. -Uh, Martin Van Buren,
I like him.
A lot of... he... he is somebody
that doesn't get enough credit.
I know... I know pneumonia
took that man down.
-Uh...
-William Henry Harrison?
-Was that... What'd I say?
-You said Martin Van Buren.
-Are you correcting me right
now? -I am correcting you.
But I have to do it
for the sanctity of this show.
Martin Van Buren was
the eighth president,
who came after Andrew Jackson,
-the seventh president. -Why
are you doing this right now?
Why are you doing this
right now, Tim?
'Cause I have to set
the record straight?
Why are you doing this?
-'Cause we have to stand atop
a foundation
of integrity and truth.
-We also create our own records.
-We have to do it.
What we do is
we have our records.
And the other two foundations
are anger toward the libs
and knowing that the globalists
are trying to take us down.
So we have integrity, honesty,
anger toward the libs...
But history is written
by the winners.
...and the globalist agenda
that we hate.
-History is... -Those are
our four founding pillars.
-Right? -History is written
by the winners.
Just like the four presidents
that we have named:
Andrew Jackson,
the seventh president,
Martin Van Buren,
who counts as two
because he's got a long name,
as the eighth president...
-Mm-hmm. -and then
William Henry Harrison,
who counts-- well, he probably
counts as more than two guys
because he's got an even longer
name than Martin Van Buren.
I'm gonna stop talking
'cause I'm leaking secrets
-about the show.
-(laughter)
-What the (bleep), man?
-What?
-William Henry Harrison died
after... because...
After 9/11, is that
what you were going to say?
There are some people
that say...
I know there are.
...that his pneumonia was a way
to get him out of office,
-Mm-hmm.
-by the Whig Party,
and then they put him on ice,
and then...
they were gonna resurrect him
at any point
to become the true successor
to the American crown...
-I mean, the presidency.
-(laughter)
Go to Tim's blog-- he has
a lot of this laid out for us.
-Yeah, that's true. -That's
all the time we have today.
But if you at home
have any questions,
give us a call at...
...and leave a voice mail with
your name and where you're from,
and we might use it on the show.
And if you'd rather e-mail,
too bad.
-(laughter)
-I was... recently hacked,
and now I'm being cyber-bullied
by a neighborhood teen.
-(laughter)
-So... I had to go off the grid.